the most famous voice of Romania for
kids during the last year of communism I
boys over 3,000 titles because it was
illegal it was an opening to freedom my
name is Serina Margaret Aniston I'm a
film critic but first of all I'm a film
lover
starting with 1980 the siren carton was
Romania life was very difficult for
everybody
Romania had just two hours of TV and of
course it was a very harsh censorship
thing I start working for the national
television the only television in
Romania and I was working there as
translator to see what we supposed to
cut they weren't interested in showing
anything connected with religion sex and
so on about to food because we couldn't
find many of this product everything
that showed that there were full shops
and solving medicine
for us it was extraordinary to see a
mall the only salvation was PC ours was
a black market for these years on that
time it was the only window to the
Western world in 1985 a business man
approached me - voiceover his videos the
beginning of a beautiful friendship so I
was translating all kinds of film all
kinds missed our team Bruce very
romantic films and I think Morris Van
Damme Bruce Avenger
grumble avocadoes I was trying to let
the actors be hurt first and then my
voice took me 12 hours for one film and
I was supposed to do that very quickly
in order to be to be spread all over
Romania it seems that they were million
to watch the tape before the Revolution
I think this film seldom Jew pass
through a very difficult period with
some moments of happiness it's
absolutely essential to to fight for art
without censorship because it's not
resort and then it goes to politics and
so on it's extremely important to have
freedom of speech because we know so
well how it was not to have freedom of
speech
you